in this episode we're going to build a
user authentication system with angular
4 and firebase authentication is
required in almost every angular
application including this basic to do
list app the F currently has no
authentication at all but we want the
user to be able to log in with their
Google Facebook Twitter or github
account at this point it is assumed that
the angular fire to package is installed
and bootstrapped in your app if not go
to the docs or check out this video we
are going to keep this feature super
simple the off service will handle all
the interaction with the firebase API
the user login component will handle the
login and logout actions from the user
and the user profile component will show
details about the user that are returned
from firebase head over to your firebase
project and enable the providers you
want to use for non Google providers you
will need to get your own developer
account and API keys the way you handle
authentication with firebase is by
subscribing to the angularfire auth
observable which returns a firebase off
state object now that we have the off
state object we can take advantage of
typescript accessories to get attribute
[Music]
here's the beauty of firebase you can
implement for social off providers with
very little codes I start by creating a
reusable private function that takes the
provider as an argument called social
sign-on when a user attempts to sign in
two things can happen success or failure
when it's the success the den code will
execute and if it's a error the catch
code will execute at this point you may
be wondering what's the update user data
function is about it's optional but you
may want to save user records to the
firebase real-time database whenever a
user logs in it can be useful if you
plan on iterating over users in your app
or if you collect additional data during
signup we finish off the service by
creating an action for each of the four
providers this is as simple as returning
the result of the social sign-in
function with the off service complete
we can now inject it into any component
here's how you might create a log in
component with functions to log in or
sign out a user with each provider in
the template we can then bind these
functions to the click event the
accessor zwi created in the service come
in handy in the template for adding
conditional logic that can tell whether
or not a user signed in or whether they
have a certain access level to some
content EPS up box with firebase check
out our full firebase lock article for
more details on this code and I'll see
you next time
[Music]